JUDITH SINGER: Thank
you all for coming out
this afternoon for the 10th
annual New Faculty Institute.
This is the 10th year
we have been hosting
these events for
new faculty from all
across Harvard University.
I'm Judy Singer.
I'm the Senior Vice Provost
for Faculty Development
and Diversity.
And I'm also a professor of
statistics at the Graduate
School of Education.
I will come back and
make a few remarks,
but we're privileged to have
Provost Alan Garber joining us.
And I thought rather than
me start and then turn over
to Alan, I'm just going
to turn it over to Alan
to come and make a few remarks.
And he'll also take some
questions from you--
if you wonder what
a provost does,
which is often a question
that people wonder.
So Alan, why don't
you come on over.
ALAN GARBER: Can you hear
me OK without the mic?
Half the room?
OK.
I'll use the mic.
Thanks.
First of all, let me
thank Judy and her office
for organizing this event.
It's an example of the wonderful
work that her office does.
And I'm going to be pretty
brief in my welcoming comments.
But there's a reason
why I want to emphasize
what her office does.
You all came here for
different reasons--
presumably, because of the
professional opportunities.
But what that means in
each case, I'm sure,
is different among you.
For some of you, it's about
your immediate colleagues.
For some of you, it's about the
students in your department,
perhaps in your school.
It may have a lot to do with
the kinds of collaborations
that you can have.
And you're also at different
levels of seniority.
Some of you are beginning
assistant professors.
Some of you are tenured
faculty here at Harvard.
So what that means
is I'm not going
to take your time
by telling you what
you need to do to get tenure.
And by the way, when
the provost says that,
it sounds almost like it's
a contract or a guarantee
or something, so I'm
not going to go there.
But there is one
common bit of advice
that I'd like to give
all of you, which
is to truly take advantage of
what Harvard University has
to offer.
Well, what do I mean by that?
There's the obvious
kinds of resources
that you have available
to you for your research,
and for your teaching and so on.
But for many
people, it's so easy
to become fully
engaged in what's
going on in your school
or your department
that you might lose
sight of what's
going on in the rest
of the university,
and how you might benefit
from becoming involved
in the university more broadly.
And in fact, today's event,
where we bring together
people from all
over the university,
is actually not as common
as I would like it to be.
And this is part of what
Judy's office works on--
to bring together faculty
from across the university.
Now, especially if you're a
beginning assistant professor,
you may be thinking,
well, don't I
need to worry about getting
my papers published,
my research done, all
the other things that you
need to do to get your
career off the ground.
That's all necessary.
But if you don't take
advantage of the fact
that you have colleagues
with expertise in virtually
every academic endeavor,
who, if nothing else,
will educate you in
a very broad sense--
if you don't take
advantage of that,
then you're missing out of
a lot of what makes Harvard
such a special place.
There are extraordinary
people here
in every field and
extraordinary resources.
And we have dinners for
faculty, other kinds of events,
to make sure that
there are opportunities
to get to know people
outside your area.
Occasionally, new research
collaborations form.
Often, friendships form.
You have a lot in
common with people who
aren't in your immediate area.
I urge you to seek opportunities
to take advantage of that.
It's not only about faculty.
It's also about
sometimes sharing
students for collaboration.
Students and postdocs-- as many
of you who are experienced,
tenured faculty
certainly know that--
are often the glue
that will hold together
interdisciplinary
collaborations.
There is another part of Harvard
that I would urge you not
to overlook, and that's our
many cultural institutions
and resources.
I'll just mention a few that
report to the provost's office.
There is the-- well, this isn't
exactly a cultural institution,
but the Harvard Library.
It's the largest university
library in the world.
And when I say library,
by the way, some of you
are probably surprised
I used the singular.
It's many libraries,
many different buildings.
There are many, many treasures
to be found in the library.
There is the
Harvard Art Museums.
By some measures, it's the
sixth largest art museum
in the country.
And it's an unusual museum.
It's quite new.
It only opened a few years ago.
And it's set up to
be a teaching museum.
You will find that,
for many of you,
it can be a resource
for your teaching.
And they support various kinds
of courses in many subjects,
not only those
related to, say, art--
or even, not only
the humanities.
And then there's the ART, the
American Repertory Theater,
which is a theater that every
year typically gets a Tony
Award for a play that
was developed there
and is brought to New York.
So I could go on and on.
There's many different kinds
of musical opportunities,
and so on.
This is an amazing
community that's
just full of life and vitality.
And if you don't take advantage
of all there is to offer,
it's not as though you
will have a bad experience,
but you really missed out.
So I urge you to get to know
your colleagues, and especially
today, take the opportunities
to get to know the people who
are here.
And then, I hope
I'll get a chance
to talk with you again
about what we look
for to make tenure decisions.
But that's a story
for another day.
You have a great panel
here to hear from,
who will be able to tell you
a lot more than I can about
how you manage the various
demands on your time,
how you manage life
as a faculty member.
They are people who
are in the thick of it,
at a somewhat different stage
of their careers than I am.
So I don't want to
take much more time.
But let me ask if there are
any questions or comments.
Well, I hope this means that
all your questions have already
been answered.
Well, let me just
turn it over to Judy.
Do you want to
introduce the panel?
JUDITH SINGER: Yep.
ALAN GARBER: Oh, you're
going to have [INAUDIBLE]..
JUDITH SINGER: Thank you, Alan.
Alan has to run off
to his next meeting.
One of the things provosts do
is they make opening remarks.
[LAUGHTER]
So let me just make a few
comments about Harvard
in general.
And then I'm going to have
everybody go around the room
and introduce
themselves, very briefly,
and then turn it
over to my colleague
Elizabeth Ancarana, the
Assistant Provost for Faculty
Development and Diversity, who
will moderate and facilitate
the panel.
As I said earlier,
I've been here awhile.
I actually started as a
faculty member in 1984
when I was three years old.
And it was pretty amazing that
they hired three-year-olds
at that time.
But Harvard didn't
have a tenure track.
So you could hire
a three-year-old,
and you wouldn't expect
that they would actually
grow up to get tenure.
I did get tenure in 1993.
And I want to share with
you a few lessons that I've
learned more from my
provostial perch, probably
in contrast to
some of the things
that you'll hear from some
of our colleagues here.
One is about the size
of the university.
Harvard is a very,
very large place.
So we have, not counting
our affiliated hospitals,
where there are another
12,000 faculty--
I did not add zeros.
There are 12,000 faculty in the
Harvard affiliated hospitals.
There are 1,500 ladder
faculty at the university.
About 1,100 of them are tenured.
That's nearly 3/4 of the
ladder faculty are tenured.
And the remaining are assistant
and associate professors--
tenure track faculty.
The language of
having a tenure track
is relatively new at Harvard.
Each of you were hired
with the expectation
that we would nurture
your careers here.
And we would like to
see you succeed here.
That doesn't mean everybody
will, but what it means
is we have an investment.
It's very much in
contrast to what
happened when I was
initially hired,
which was assume you will not
get tenure, which basically
is a great way to get people to
not invest in the institution.
And so part of what
we've done-- this
is entirely enlightened
self-interest.
And the enlightened
self interest
is by having a tenure track, we
are more likely to hire faculty
at the assistant and
associate professor
level who will invest
in their careers
here, invest in their teaching--
we do take teaching
seriously here--
and contribute to
the environment
and the life of the university.
The university is also
increasingly diverse.
You'd never know it by seeing
portraits in these rooms--
they're mostly dead, white men
hanging around on the walls--
but we are increasingly diverse.
Right now about 30% of the
ladder faculty are female.
About 22% are minorities.
Your entering class, the
people around the room,
is over 40% female
and 27% minority.
That's very different from
the Harvard of the past.
And that's part of a
conscious decision of working
towards inclusive excellence.
We think we can be
a stronger faculty
by being a more diverse faculty,
and by welcoming voices that
previously might not be a
part of Harvard University,
but whose voices we really
want here at the table.
The third thing that I'll
say is much more different
recently is a push towards
what President Faust calls
One Harvard.
And the One Harvard
mantra is very
different from the every tub
on its own bottom mantra.
So Harvard is a
proud institution.
It's been around
for a long time.
It's been pretty
successful and it
has operated, still operates,
on what's called a tub system.
Each one of the
schools is independent.
It sets its own tuition.
It has its own endowment.
One of the things that President
Faust wanted to foster,
and we have every expectation
that the next president
of Harvard will
continue to foster,
is the notion of One Harvard.
And this event is a very clear
illustration of the One Harvard
ethos.
We hope that you
had orientations
within your own school.
But we also want to
welcome you to being
the faculty of the university.
And as Alan mentioned, our
office hosts a lot of events
during the academic year.
Some of them are like this,
more professional development.
Some of them are purely social.
You heard Alan mention the
American Repertory Theater.
We often do faculty
nights at the ART.
We did one last week
for WARHOLCAPOTE,
which is playing at the
American Repertory Theater.
And having seen it,
I suspect this, too,
is heading to Broadway
if not a Tony Award.
And as part of these
faculty nights,
we have somebody
from the production.
Last week, we had
Rob Roth, who was
the writer of the
script of WARHOLCAPOTE,
come in and do a talk just
for the faculty with Q&A,
and get a sense
of what's involved
in the artistic production.
We're also planning,
later this semester,
media training for faculty.
Some of you have never been
approached by a reporter.
And it's important
to know how to think
about presenting yourself
and presenting your research,
and also how to work with
the public information
officers in your schools to get
word out about your research.
And so we're going to be hosting
an event in early November.
This is all, by way of saying,
is don't delete my emails
They have lots of
interesting things in them.
And I'm going to
stop there, and ask
people to go around the room
and introduce themselves.
ELIZABETH ANCARANA:
It's so great
to see you all here today.
Thanks so much for coming.
This is a large
group, and we're just
delighted to have you here.
As Judy mentioned, my name
is Elizabeth Ancarana,
and I'm the Assistant Provost
for Faculty Development
and Diversity.
I have the pleasure of
introducing our four faculty
panelists to you today.
We have four panelists, who
will each talk for about 10
or 15 minutes on various
aspects of work and life,
and navigating your
scholarly career at Harvard.
I'm going to start
with Michael Luca.
Mike is the Lee J.
Styslinger III Associate
Professor of Business
Administration
at Harvard Business School.
Mike's research uses field
experiments and observational
data to understand how online
platforms are impacting
the world, how their
data can improve
our understanding of
society and the economy,
and how to better design
the platforms themselves.
His recent research has
sought to understand
how data from Yelp can
improve our understanding
of the minimum wage, how
Airbnb's design choices have
facilitated
discrimination, and how
to rethink government disclosure
policies for the digital age.
At HBS, he teaches
a doctoral course
on field experiments
and an MBA course
on applying behavioral
insights for the social good.
Mike earned his
Bachelor's of Science
from SUNY Albany and his
PhD from Boston University.
JUDITH SINGER: Mike and I both
graduated from SUNY Albany.
We're quite happy about that.
[LAUGHTER]
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: From his
perspective as a newly promoted
associate professor,
Mike will talk
about navigating Harvard
in your department,
and pleasures of your
faculty position.
Next to Mike--
MICHAEL LUCA: I didn't
choose the topic.
[LAUGHTER]
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: Next
to Mike is Emily Balskus.
Emily is the Morris
Kahn Associate Professor
of Chemistry and
Chemical Biology
in the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences,
integrating knowledge
of microbiology
with an understanding
of biochemical logic
and organic chemistry.
Emily's research aims
to discover, understand,
and manipulate microbial
metabolism, which
is essential to life on Earth.
Her work focuses on deciphering
the chemical mechanisms
by which microorganisms living
in and on the human body
influence health and disease,
as well as developing approaches
for manipulating functions
of human-associated microbial
communities.
The Balskus Lab is uncovering
new metabolic pathways
in enzymes and microbial genome
sequencing data, and devising
strategies for integrating
synthetic organic chemistry
with microbial metabolism to
modify cellular metabolites.
Emily earned her
bachelor's degree
from Williams College
and her PhD from Harvard.
Emily, from her perspective
as an associate professor,
will talk about
mentoring, setting
priorities, and resources for
your scholarship at Harvard.
Next to Emily, we have our
two tenured faculty members.
We have Sara Bleich.
Sara is a professor of public
health policy at the Harvard TH
Chan School of Public Health and
the Department of Health Policy
and Management.
She's also the Carol K.
Pforzheimer Professor
at the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study.
Sara's scholarship lies at
the nexus of health policy
and health services research.
Her work provides evidence to
support policy alternatives
for obesity prevention
and control,
particularly among
populations of higher
risk for this disease.
A signature theme
throughout her research
is an interest in asking
simple yet meaningful questions
about the complex
problem of obesity,
which can fill important
gaps in the literature.
During the Obama
administration, Sara also
served as a White House Fellow,
where she was a senior policy
advisor to the US
Department of Agriculture
and the first lady's
Let's Move! initiative.
Sara holds a bachelor's
degree from Columbia
and a PhD from Harvard.
Sara is going to focus, from
her vantage point as a recently
tenured faculty member, on
establishing your reputation
as a scholar, navigating
the new tenure review
process, mentoring and
your life at Harvard,
and some other tips.
And finally, we
have Jason Mitchell.
Jason is a professor of
psychology in the Faculty
of Arts and Sciences.
And he's also taken on the
role as faculty director
of Harvard's Program
in General Education.
Jason uses neural
imaging techniques
to study the brain basis of
human social interaction,
especially how we make sense
of the thoughts, feelings,
and personalities
of those around us.
Situated in the field of
social cognitive neuroscience,
his research makes use of new
imaging techniques developed
by cognitive neuroscientists
to illuminate,
in innovative ways,
long-standing questions
in social psychology around
how the brain processes
information.
His experimental
work has produced
four general discoveries
around social cognition,
understanding the minds of
others, our future self,
and altruistic behavior.
Jason received his bachelor's
and master's degrees
from Yale University and
his PhD from Harvard.
From his vantage point as
a tenured faculty member,
Jason will talk about
teaching, teaching resources,
and his experience
teaching at Harvard.
So welcome.
And why don't we
begin with you, Mike.
Mike?
MICHAEL LUCA: Great.
Good afternoon, everybody.
I just wanted to start by
saying that I'm honored
and humbled to have
the opportunity
to chat with you all today.
When Judy invited
me to speak here,
I remember my initial
thought was, oh, well,
that must have been
meant for somebody else.
After all, she was looking
for an esteemed faculty member
to come participate in this.
But before she could change
her mind, I responded quickly.
And at that point,
I think it would
have been too awkward to
rescind the invitation.
So here I am.
So when I started
thinking about the things
that I wanted to
share today, my mind
started drifting, actually,
back to before I was a faculty
member here, and to when I was
a graduate student at Boston
University.
I remember in April 2010,
I had gotten a phone call
from a friend and a
classmate, who had implored
me to come to the office.
Our offices were
actually, literally
converted bathrooms on the
fifth floor of the economics
building there.
"Hurry," he told me, "you've
got to come see this."
So I went into the office.
And when I arrived, I
remember he opened a browser
to show me a blog post about a
paper we had been working on.
And the blog post
was by Al Roth,
who's a leading economist,
who was then at Harvard.
I'll kind of gloss over the
fact that he's now at Stanford--
conversation for another day.
So we had never met Al at that
point, but we were Al groupies.
We knew the research,
and we were fans.
And this was a big deal for us.
Looking back now-- I went
back and found the blog post.
Actually, it turns
out it wasn't really
a blog post so much as
a sentence with a link
to our paper.
But that was enough for us.
So I remember, that day,
this felt like a big break.
So we went over to
celebrate-- how else would one
celebrate other than to
have chai lattes with skim
milk at the Starbucks down the
street from Boston University.
And of course, later we went
and told our parents about this.
So I remember, a year
and a half later, I
was invited to interview
at Harvard Business School.
And I hadn't really
been at business schools
before, let alone
Harvard Business School.
And I saw that Al was on
my interview schedule.
So I sat there, and
I was preparing.
I prepared my content,
but also prepared what
should I say when I
finally have a chance
to meet Professor Roth.
Hello, Professor Roth.
I thought, no, that's
maybe too formal.
Hey Al, good to see you.
I was like, no, that doesn't
quite seem right either.
So in any case, I
arrived at Al's office,
and we chatted about research.
The day went well.
And ultimately, I ended
up getting and accepting
an offer at HBS, for which
I'm all very grateful.
But there was one
part of the day that
stuck with me for the years.
And it was kind of an
idiosyncratic interaction
that I had had with Al as
I was leaving his office.
He may be horrified
that I'm sharing this.
He said, "Here's a piece of
advice for the job market."
I leaned in, waiting to hear
what the words of wisdom from
this future Nobel laureate-- who
now has won the Nobel Prize--
had to say to me.
And Al leaned over,
and I remember
he said, "If you see
a bathroom, use it."
And the advice was,
"Otherwise, you just
don't know when you're
going to have another chance
to get into a bathroom
on the job market."
And this actually stuck
with me through the years
for multiple reasons.
One, it's useful.
And when I go on
talks I still kind of
have this in the
back of my head.
But it also stuck with me
because this was the moment
that I first realized
that Al wasn't just
a giant in the field, that
Al was actually a very kind
person, a thoughtful person,
and an empathetic person.
And for me, my interaction with
Al on that day was basically
my vision of what Harvard is
when it's at its best, which
is, at its best,
the university life
provides this
opportunity to engage
with inspiring colleagues,
the opportunity
to teach, to mentor, to
learn from students--
here we have amazing
students-- and the opportunity
to have a unique platform for
creating change and sharing
knowledge with the
world around us.
And importantly, it's an
environment that, at its best,
is so supportive that
your colleagues all
want to make sure that you have
a chance to go to the bathroom
before your next meeting.
So when thinking about
Harvard, though, Harvard also
has a set of challenges.
And this is what I was
thinking about when
reflecting on navigating
the Harvard system.
And when I think
about the reasons
that sometimes the
promise of Harvard
isn't realized for individual
faculty members who
are navigating it, I see
three challenges that,
at least for me, come to mind.
The first is those
inspiring colleagues--
they could also be
intimidating as hell.
So you're in there, and
these are amazing minds
that you're surrounded by.
And sometimes, by assembling
a large group of impressive,
quick-on-their-feet,
often opinionated people,
this could create a culture of
self-doubt and an environment
in which it's easy to feel
like wherever you are,
you need to have
your game face on.
Second-- and this seems like a
little bit of a paradox after
the first thing I said--
is that we're surrounded
by fascinating people,
but Harvard can also be
a lonely place if you
let it be a lonely place.
And I'll circle back to the
relationship between this
and One Harvard in a little
bit, but many of your colleagues
will have unimaginably busy
schedules, between research,
teaching, lectures, and-- at
least one case that I could
think about--
a cameo in the latest
Spider-Man movie.
And if you haven't seen it
yet, you should watch it.
And at times, when
thinking about that,
it's hard to find
your community.
I remember once taking
a train to New York
just to catch up with lunch from
a colleague from the economics
department here.
So third-- and this
also seems a little bit
funny on the surface--
which is that there's
a lot of things going on at
Harvard, as you mentioned.
And I know what you're thinking.
Oh, isn't that great?
Isn't that the
reason we're here?
How is that challenging?
But actually, it's great to
have so many things going on,
but it could also
be overwhelming.
And it's overwhelming
when you're
trying to balance your research,
your teaching, attending
seminars, giving talks, while
also trying to find time
for friends, family, and
the latest episode of Game
of Thrones.
And if anybody knows what
happened in the last one,
please don't tell me.
I haven't quite
caught up on it yet.
So with this in
mind, I just wanted
to share a few thoughts about
navigating the Harvard system,
and about overcoming
some of these challenges
to make sure that you could
get as much from it as I
feel like I've been able
to get out of it now.
And I think it has
a lot of promise.
The first thing that I think
about is to seek advice.
So when thinking about
being a faculty member
rather than being a graduate
student-- especially for people
who are new here-- as
a graduate student,
it's very easy to seek advice.
It's sort of part and
parcel of being a student.
But then when you start
looking for a job,
there is a little bit of
a change in the ethos.
You start polishing
your research.
You start practicing
for interviews.
You prepare for any question
that might be thrown your way.
And if you don't
have an answer, you
know why you don't
have an answer
and how you would
go about getting it.
And then when you start
as a faculty member,
sometimes it's easy to
stay in this mindset
and think that you're
always being evaluated,
or that you always should have
the answers to everything.
But when I think
about that, I think
that's sometimes a mistake.
And I think that
you're missing out
by not seeking the advice
from your colleagues.
Why?
Because here's the thing.
When thinking about the
colleagues in your department,
the people who
hired you like you.
And they want you to succeed.
And you're actually
surrounded by people
who care about your success,
otherwise none of you
would be here today.
And for me, I really think
it's important to just
let that sink in, and to feel
comfortable seeking out advice
from your senior
colleagues and mentors.
And linking this back to this
feeling of needing a game face,
I think it's important sometimes
to just take your game face off
and to share your successes,
but also your struggles,
your thoughts, your concerns,
the things that you're not sure
what the answer is to.
And remember that seeking
advice doesn't mean
following everybody's advice.
It just means hearing
what people have to say
and understanding that
some of the advice
is going to be contradictory,
but this way you
could get a broader
perspective on the challenges
that you are facing.
Now, second-- cross bridges.
And now I should caveat that--
I don't mean that in a
deep metaphorical sense.
I mean that in a literal sense.
The Larz Anderson Bridge is
finally done with construction.
It's actually quite nice now.
And if you still
don't like that one,
you could cross between
HBS and Harvard Square
on the walking bridge
down the street from it.
So the reason I say this is
because, for me personally,
I've found it a privilege to
be part of the Harvard Business
School community,
but I've also found
a great set of collaborators
around the university
more broadly.
So I've had co-authors
in the Kennedy
School of the economics
department, the psychology
department.
I've presented in the
computer science department.
And last year, I organized a
workshop with a group of people
from the sociology department.
And I didn't actually
know any of these people
before I came to the university.
These are just people who,
through chance encounters,
I had the opportunity to
meet in my years here.
And overall,
thinking about this,
part of what's
facilitated this is
that people are generally
excited about their work
and about exchanging ideas.
And also, a little bit
of practical advice.
As a practical matter,
Crema and Henrietta's Table
are convenient to many
different schools--
so an easy meeting place
for those looking to do so.
So the thing that I would
want to take away for that is
to enjoy your department-- so I
love the unit that I'm located
in--
but also to find what I think
about as a vacation home
in another part of the school.
So third comes down to
teaching at Harvard.
When I think about
teaching, for me, there's
a switch I really
turned on here,
which was the idea that we
really, at the heart of it,
should be enjoying our
teaching and enjoying
working with students.
When thinking about the role
of students at the university,
they really are vital to
the intellectual vibrancy
that all of us feel.
And I think there is sometimes
a little bit of bias,
I think, about, oh, my
students are my mini-mes,
or my students are my workforce,
or my students are people
I want to impart something on.
But I think that
relationships with students
are best when you respect your
students, and learn from them
as well as feeling like
you're just teaching them.
And it reminds me of this
moment in Kung Fu Panda 3--
don't pretend you haven't
seen it, I know many of you
probably have--
where the protagonist, Po, comes
to this important realization
about teaching after almost
giving up, and feeling
like he's not a great teacher.
And I remember, he realizes
that his goal as a teacher
is not just to help the
students to be like him.
His job is to help the
students be the best them
that they could be, and to
help find their strengths.
So when I think
about when I've had
the most successful
collaborations with,
or engagements with,
students at the university
has been when I've thought
about students and the things
that they would
need, and the fact
that the things
that worked for you
may not work for your
doctoral students,
or may not work for
the MBA students
you're teaching in a
classroom, and thinking
about what the
different strengths they
have in the different approaches
to teaching there are.
Forth is the fact
that there is a lot
of strongly established norms.
And we were even talking
before this panel about,
sometimes norms vary across
different parts of the school.
And one thing that I think
people underappreciate
is that sometimes it's
good to break norms.
So there are some norms that
make a lot of sense and that
are good to have in place,
but there are a lot of norms
that are just norms for--
I don't even know why
they became norms.
For me, I had one
personal experience
with this when I
had my first son.
At Harvard Business
School, there
wasn't a real norm for fathers
to take parental leave at HBS.
I remember, the
idea was essentially
that you would teach
your class as usual,
and on the day that
the baby arrived,
you would have people
on call to cover
for the next couple of days.
They would cover your
class, and then you'd
get back to teaching
shortly thereafter.
And I remember, after
our conversation
with a mentor who--
note aforementioned
advice-seeking--
I chatted with
and thought about,
is this something I want to do.
I'd like to spend more time
with my son when he's born.
I decided to ignore that norm
and to take parental leave
so I could spend time
doing things that parents
of new babies want to do--
change diapers, not sleep,
and get to know your child.
And I remember that I had
a very awkward conversation
in the department about
wanting to do this.
But once I actually
got it out there,
despite the fact that there
wasn't a strong norm of this,
people were actually
very supportive of it.
And looking back on it, it
was amazing to spend this time
together with my son.
And in retrospect,
I can't imagine
not having spent that time
home and away from work.
So lastly, I just wanted
to end on a positive note.
So I wanted to
quote the economist
John Maynard Keynes, who
in the typical optimism
of an economist said, "In the
long run, we're all dead."
[LAUGHTER]
And this brings me
to the broader point,
which is something that I
would want people to take away
with them today, which
is that we're often
told about the things that
we could do after tenure,
and to play it safe while
you're going for a promotion,
and to optimize a
little bit to that.
And when I think about
this, I sometimes
feel that this
advice is misguided.
And the way, at least
that I've thought
about navigating, as a
junior faculty member,
through the
university is that we
have a limited amount of time.
So I think sometimes the
best that we could do
is just think about the
time that we have here,
and the impact that you can have
while you're fortunate to be
in this environment.
So I tend to think about
things in a shorter horizon
than the 35-year, here's what
I'm going to do down the road.
And for me, this has meant
taking unconventional risks
at times-- so taking on
untraditional research
projects, teaching
untraditional courses.
So at HBS, this means things
that are not only based
on cases, but also things
that are in the field,
and even courses that are
cross-listed with the Kennedy
School--
and hoping that if I do things
that are high impact, and that
are important, and, for
me, fun, that other people
will find them to
be that as well.
So for me, it
also, though, means
remembering that there
is life beyond Harvard.
And on a practical level,
we have a commitment device
that we set for ourselves
in our household, which
is to try to have a
day trip every week.
So some of the things that we
like to do in the Boston area--
for people who are new--
include going to Rockport
for a lobster at Roy Moore,
Salem for a day trip to
the Peabody Essex Museum,
and the deCordova Sculpture
Park for an afternoon
stroll with our kids.
And the last thing that I want
to note is that some of those
places, actually, you
get free admission
if you bring your Harvard ID.
And for some that don't-- the
Outings & Innings website,
which I don't know if
it's managed by your--
JUDITH SINGER: It's not.
[INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL LUCA: Got it.
So they have great
discounts, though,
for a lot of things
in the Boston area.
So I'll stop here for now.
But I'm looking forward
to chatting more.
[APPLAUSE]
EMILY BALSKUS: OK.
It looks like I'm next.
So I'd just like to start
by echoing everyone else
and welcoming you to Harvard.
So you're about to start a
really amazing both academic as
well as personal journey here.
And I guarantee you'll
learn things you never
imagined, and not just in
the context of your research
and your scholarship.
So I think I'll start with the
ending, sort of the punch line.
My overall message that I want
to convey today is really,
I think, to embrace
this experience
as a learning opportunity--
so really, the next step
in your own education.
And just like every
previous step,
I think you'll mature as
a scholar and as a teacher
as you go along.
And for me at least, I
think viewing my time
as a junior faculty
member through this lens
has been incredibly
helpful in dealing
with the obstacles,
stresses, and anxieties
that I think
inevitably accompany
this type of position.
So the specific
things that I wanted
to talk to all about today
are establishing yourself
as a scholar, with a
particular focus on resources
for scholarship that
are available here,
and also priority setting.
And then secondly, mentoring--
both in the context
of being mentored by others
and mentoring others.
And I want to note
before I start
that, because I'm an
experimental scientist,
some of the things that have
been really important for me
are definitely not
going to be universally
applicable to everyone.
And likewise, if some
of the scientists
here have additional
questions about things
that I won't have
time to cover, I'd
be happy to chat with anyone
outside of this event.
So first, in thinking
about establishing yourself
as a scholar here at
Harvard, one piece
of advice that I have,
that I especially
extend the scientists, is
to get started right away--
not just with your
research, but also
in building relationships within
and outside of the university.
So especially if you're
an experimental scientist,
I think it can be
really easy to focus
a lot of your time and energy
on preparing to do research.
So your lab space might
not be finished yet.
There's always a lot of
things to order and to get up
and running.
Make sure that as
you're doing this,
you're also still
engaging with, especially,
grad students within
the department-- also,
your colleagues both in and
outside of your department.
You start thinking about
writing grants and proposals.
It may seem like
it's a long way away
before you feel
ready to do that,
but I think you know the
experience of attempting
to write these things early
on is really, really helpful.
You go to meetings
in your field,
even though you
might not actually
have independent work
ready to present.
Early on, start figuring
out what resources on campus
can be helpful to you.
So for example, for scientists,
if you start reaching out
to staff in the dean's office--
Jeremy Bloxham's staff--
you can learn a lot
about funding opportunities.
You can look at
example proposals.
This is something that I
started doing right away,
and it was really helpful.
If you know, for
example, that there
are facilities or instruments
somewhere within Harvard that
would be helpful to your
research eventually,
I'd really urge you
to start getting
in touch with those people,
exploring those resources, now.
The university's a big place.
Things can sometimes move
more slowly than you'd like.
And so if you're
on people's radar
and you have done some of
the legwork in advance,
that can help
enormously in helping
to move things along when
you're ready to do those things.
A second message,
I think, is take
advantage of this opportunity
to explore in your scholarship.
So don't be afraid to step
outside of your comfort zone
and move into new areas
if you see that there are
really exciting opportunities.
So this is really, I think,
personally relevant for me.
The research work I'm
actually now best known
for was not something
that I proposed to work
on when I applied for jobs.
It wasn't even
something that I had
explored in any previous
training experience.
And so it's been
really amazing to have
had the opportunity to kind of
start off in a new direction.
And I think I'd just advise
everyone to believe in yourself
and trust your
scholarly instincts.
It really, I think,
is not the time
to be too conservative when
it comes to your scholarship.
And I think that, with that
spirit of exploration in mind,
I'd also encourage everyone to
try to seek out organizations
and initiatives that lie outside
of your own research group
and department to
get involved in.
And so I had the
opportunity pretty early on
to get involved in the Microbial
Sciences Initiative, which--
across the sciences,
there are many initiatives
like this that are designed
to bring together professors,
graduate students, and postdocs
from different departments,
different schools,
who are interested
in similar questions.
In our case, it's studies
of the microbial world.
And this was incredibly helpful.
I made a lot of connections
to faculty members
at other departments
and schools.
I met some current collaborators
through people in the MSI.
My first graduate
students and postdocs
could get help with experiments
we weren't as familiar with,
because we had met people
through this organization.
So it really helped to
shape my research program.
And also, I think, just gave me,
pretty early on-- since I was
such an enthusiastic
contributor--
a lot of visibility among that
group of people on campus.
So another piece
of advice that I
have found to be really
helpful in my own work
is to try as much as possible
to integrate your scholarship
into other activities
and obligations
that you have to do-- things
like teaching and service.
And so I've had a
couple of opportunities
to design new classes.
And every time I've done this--
both at the graduate level
and, actually, at the
undergraduate level
in the context of a
freshman seminar--
I've tried to frame the courses
around areas of science that
are closely related to my
own research interests.
And so you can then use
the time you're spending
preparing for the class--
it benefits you, because
it's research time as well.
And even when I teach a big
undergraduate class-- so
I've taught, in the past,
undergraduate organic
chemistry.
And I'd try to find sometimes
subtle, sometimes not-so-subtle
ways of introducing
concepts and themes
that I'm excited about in
my research into lectures.
And this is not only, I think,
a good way to engage students,
really introducing them
to questions and ideas
that practicing scientists
are interested in,
but I think it's also
a really good way
to practice communicating
your science
and research to an audience
of non-specialists,
which will pay dividends
in a lot of other contexts.
So one other thing
that I'll mention
is the importance of
building good time management
skills right from the start,
and making your scholarly work
a priority.
So I kind of alluded to
all these other activities.
I'm sure you're starting
to experience this--
if you haven't started
to experience it yet--
there is a lot of
additional obligations
that you'll have to deal with
that you potentially have not
experienced before.
And I think that it can be an
obstacle for, particularly,
new faculty at the
assistant professor level
to try to manage scholarly
work in the context
of these other obligations.
And the big problem
is that of course
all these other
obligations usually
have deadlines attached to them.
And so it's really easy
to sort of push other work
aside to get those seemingly
more urgent things finished.
And so there are a lot of ways
to deal with this problem.
One thing that's
worked well for me
is to try to organize my
schedule so that I place
time blocks that are
dedicated to certain things
like writing and reading.
I'll try to carve out very
specific periods of time
to prepare for class,
and not really let
myself spend time outside of
those blocks on certain things.
I think the other
thing to remember
is that research, at
least in the context
of experimental science,
I think it always takes
longer than you think it will.
So I think for me
it's been a goal
to try to find a balance in
terms of time management,
where I can keep up a steady
pace with a lot of the writing
and travel, all the
other components
of scholarly activities, that
is manageable, not overwhelming,
but allows me to
make steady progress
over long, long periods of time.
And so I think, again, there
are many different solutions
to that problem.
But really, having
time management
at the forefront
of your mind as you
start to tackle some of
these new responsibilities
can be helpful.
And with this in mind, I
think one of the things
that hopefully you'll do here--
building bonds with
younger colleagues
can be really helpful.
It's great to exchange ideas
about those types of things.
I know that some of my newly
tenured female colleagues
in science, they actually have
a weekly lunch meeting where
they'll get
together, have lunch,
and each person will bring
a problem or a question
that they'd like to pose
the rest of the group
to get advice about.
So you can organize
those types of groups
with colleagues
in your department
or in other departments.
Then, I think the last thing I
want to say about scholarship,
is really, it's
been very helpful
for me to approach my scholarly
work with a growth mindset.
I think it's really easy to
feel like everybody expects
you to already be the scholar
that you'll be in seven years
right now, or that
because you've been hired
to be at a place like
this that you have
to be successful at
everything you attempt to do,
all the time.
And I can reassure you
that's not the case.
And as I mentioned earlier,
I've found it very helpful
to think about what I can learn
from each of the experiences
that I've encountered
during the process of being
a junior faculty member.
So having this growth
mindset makes it a lot easier
to deal with things like
rejected papers, rejected
grants, teaching evaluations,
and things like that.
So the next topic I wanted
to touch on is mentoring.
And as I think probably
everyone knows,
you'll have both formal mentors
here as well as, hopefully,
informal mentors.
And I know the formal
side of mentoring
can differ a lot between
departments, between schools.
And so what I have
to say probably
applies mostly to thinking
about informal mentors
and interactions with them.
And so one piece of
advice, again, that
has been very important for
me has been to find mentors
in multiple departments.
Particularly if your work
is interdisciplinary,
I think it's critical
to get feedback
from scholars in
related fields that
lie outside of the expertise
that's in your department.
For me, actually, right
from the beginning,
I was encouraged to have
someone from another department
on my formal
mentoring committee,
and I think that's
been very helpful.
But I've also made
an effort to get
to know colleagues in
other departments in a more
informal way as well.
And so I'd urge
everyone, if you think
that it would be helpful to
you to have a potentially
formal mentor from
another department,
just make sure that you
ask about that opportunity.
So another piece of
advice I'm sure pretty
much everyone has
probably heard before
is to figure out, really, how
to engage each of your mentors
on an individual basis.
So some of your
mentors will really
want to talk about
the things that
are frustrating you, problems
you're encountering, and will
give good advice--
not all of them will.
Some them may be more
excited about talking
to you about teaching, or coming
to actually sit in on classes.
Others will be really
good, really engaged
when you ask them to look
at your scholarly work, look
at your papers or other
pieces of written work.
And so trying to figure out what
everyone is good at but also
really engaged
in, I think, helps
you to distribute the mentoring
burden across multiple people.
It's important, I think, to
be persistent when you're
interacting with your mentors.
You might need, in identifying
especially informal mentors,
to interact with multiple
people to figure out
who you best connect with.
I think this has been
alluded to a couple times--
you also face the obstacle
that everyone here
is really, incredibly busy.
And so it's
important to identify
when it's really important
that you interact with someone,
and be persistent when
it really matters.
But of course, planning as
far in advance as possible
also will help
with that problem.
Finding mentors who
are in your field who
are outside of Harvard has
also been something that
has really helped me a lot.
I was actually forced
to do this because all
of my graduate and postdoctoral
training was here at Harvard.
And so for certain things
like grant applications,
other opportunities,
I actually wasn't
allowed to have
reference letter writers
from within the university.
So I was forced to go out
and try to build connections
with people at other places.
And that actually was
very, very helpful.
Some of those people
were individuals
who had known me
earlier on in my career.
Some of those
people were actually
people who I had first
got to know through just
scientific collaborations.
But I think that having
that outside perspective
can be really helpful.
And of course, those
people can continue
to be supporters down the line.
So I guess then
the last thing I'd
like to say about mentoring
is that I'd encourage everyone
to get involved in
mentoring others.
So I think one reason,
at least that I
have been hesitant to reach
out to mentors in the past,
is that I always
worry about taking up
too much of someone's time.
And of course, having multiple
mentors can help with this.
But I think another
thing that's helped me
not to worry as much about
this aspect of mentoring
is really to start volunteering
my time to mentor others.
And this includes not just,
of course, the students who
are in my research group
but also other opportunities
around campus.
So there are lots of, for
example, undergraduate groups
focused on science research.
Women in Science, I've
worked with those groups.
I've participated in
the Graduate Women
in Science Mentoring Program.
Also, I try whenever I can to
help the younger colleagues
here and at other institutions.
I think not only can you
sort of pay back the time
that others have
spent helping you,
but all of these experiences
add to your general mentoring
skills.
And this will be, down the road,
beneficial for your students
that you're working with, and
with the many other people
you'll have the opportunity
to mentor during your career.
So I think those
are the major points
that I wanted to emphasize.
And once again, welcome.
I'd be really excited
to answer any questions
that you have later on.
[APPLAUSE]
SARA BLEICH: Hi, everyone.
One, it's great to be here.
I'm with the School
of Public Health.
And I want you to grain-of-salt
a lot of what I say,
because I didn't go
through the process here.
I've been back for one year.
So I'm going to try
to stay pretty general
and talk about
what I think works
as you go through
the tenure process,
but definitely
talk to people who
have been through the
process in your department.
And I would say that if I
can leave you with any advice
today, I would say
you will probably
get promoted if you can
do good, innovative work,
if you can be highly
reliable and collegial.
And those three things
become so important as you
move through the process.
And so what I want
to do is give you,
for me, what have been key
bullets that have, I think,
helped me navigate the process.
And it will hopefully be
something that you could adapt.
And the first is really where
we started with this-- what
is your professional shingle?
And so you all went around
and you said, I do x.
And the best outcome of when
you meet a new person is they
walk away and they say,
so-and-so is so interesting,
and they do blah
blah blah blah blah.
So you want to keep your shingle
short and brief and clear,
and you want it to
be able to be grown.
So for example,
I've always focused
on obesity policy,
which can take
on a zillion different forms.
But I purposely always
said obesity policy,
because I sort of knew
that I'll be in one area,
then another, then a third.
And I want to leave
myself that room to grow.
And I would imagine
all of your fields,
there's a couple of words
which would define what you do,
which you could
leave with someone.
And they can say, oh,
I met John at a party.
He has the most
interesting area of blah.
But you want to leave
someone with that impression.
If you do that, you've
sort of done your job
at whatever that interaction is.
Another is focus.
And you hear this a lot.
And I think the key is to
focus on an area that you love.
There's no point in being
focused on something
you do not like.
Because this is your life.
This is your time away
from your children.
And so pick an
area that you love.
Because it's going
to frustrate you.
It's going to make you crazy.
Things are not
going to work out.
But if you love it, and it
gets you up in the morning,
it's going to make the process
that much more enjoyable.
Another concrete
bit of advice is
you should, if you
haven't already,
pick one to three professional
conferences which you
will attend every single year.
And in doing so, begin to
build this network of people
that you know quite
well, that are outside
of the university, that
matter a lot for going
through the process.
Because they'll be the referee
letters that you get back.
And don't just go
to the conferences.
Challenge yourself that at
every single conference,
you're going to reach
out to two to four people
you've never met
before, whose work
you've cited in papers, who you
want to get to know, and make
sure you have coffee with them.
And they may be people
that are more senior.
They may be other
doctoral students.
But just gradually begin
to grow your network,
and those sorts of
things pay off dividends.
Because you'll need someone
to give a lecture somewhere.
Or, you'll need someone
to serve on x and y panel.
And someone will think,
oh, I met that person
at a conference.
They seem really nice.
Let me go ahead and invite them.
And so don't discount the value
of personal relationships.
Because I think in this world,
it really does matter a lot.
I mentioned, be reliable.
And I say that sort
of tongue-in-cheek,
but I think that the two
hardest things in life
are to do what you
say you're going
to do, and show up on time.
And we are academics, so it's
sort of like herding cats.
But I think that for
me, at least personally,
I am allergic to people that
cannot respond to email,
and I'm allergic to people
that are late to my office.
Because my time is so
precious to me, personally.
And so all of us
have our red lines.
And you just want to
think carefully about,
for your working style,
for the group that you run,
what are the things
that make it effective.
And then get rid of the things
that don't make it effective.
You can sort of think of
it as the calendar test.
You wake up every day and
you look at your calendar.
And I suspect-- well, I
know-- that all of you
are extremely bright.
So it's not the difficulty
of the work that
makes your day challenging.
It's the people that
are in your life that
are either hard to work
with, that you don't like.
And the luxury of this world
is you can pick and choose
your teams.
So I would pick
very, very carefully.
And surround
yourself with people
that, ideally, play to your
weaknesses, not your strengths,
and that help you really push
good ideas through the process.
I would be patient.
I remember on my first
day of graduate school,
I sat down with my mentor--
this is Bob Blendon, who's in
the School of Public Health--
and he said--
he said, "Sara"-- and I'm
a very impatient person--
he said, "you have to
have staying power.
You have to chip on
an issue long enough
to really have an influence."
And in academic
research, you never quite
know when that moment's
going to come along.
And so you do this because
you love the field,
and you love to sort
of pull at threads.
But that does require, I think,
a high degree of patience--
both with the process of
academia and with yourself.
And so I think setting
reasonable benchmarks
and not making
yourself too crazy
becomes very important
along the way.
And the last piece, and this
goes back to the conferencing
piece, but it's a
broader point about,
you'll hear people say network.
And I'm going to reiterate,
you really should network.
And so Alan mentioned,
get out in the school
and try out different things.
And those are all
opportunities for networking.
And this is an opportunity
for networking.
Walking down the hall is an
opportunity for networking.
My post when I finished
graduate school was at Hopkins.
And I was there for eight years.
And I think in my first year, I
had coffee with like 60 people.
Because I'd meet with
someone and I'd say,
oh, is there anyone
else that you really
admire that you think
I should talk to--
often unrelated to my field.
And the act of buying
someone a cup of coffee that
maybe cost me $2,
that act of kindness
paid so many dividends.
Like, you'd run
into someone they'd
say, oh, that was so nice of you
to buy me that cup of coffee.
My first year I'm like, really?
But over and over again
I had that reaction.
And it was also just kind of
nice to get to know people.
Your time is so precious.
But I'd say particularly
for those of you
that are brand new to
the school and don't
have a lot of exposure here,
just take the time to get out.
Maybe every week
you say to yourself,
I'm going to email a new person.
I'm going to try to get
to know someone new.
And it really is both
helpful for understanding
how different the university
is across schools,
but then just, ideally,
having people at your level
that become mentors
and peers and people
that you can relate to.
So that's sort of reputation.
And then switching over to
navigating the tenure process,
thinking globally--
not just about Harvard--
I think, again, do good work.
Don't make yourself crazy trying
to get through the Harvard
process.
Just do good academic
work and make
yourself promotable anywhere.
And ideally, you will make
it through this process.
But the thing to remember is
all of us, I would imagine,
are in prime years of our lives.
We are at childbearing years.
We're at getting-married years.
We're at having a life.
And so this job is
important, but so, too,
is everything else.
And if you make yourself
crazy to get through a process
and then don't make it through,
it's not going to feel so good.
But if you just do good work
that makes you professionally
happy, you will
be happy anywhere
where you do that work.
And I would just sort of keep
that in the back of your mind.
I would also be--
and this is something
that has helped me
hugely as a mom,
which is level-set people
from the beginning.
When I first had my
daughter, who's--
the oldest is six, the youngest
is four-- someone said to me,
don't do anything when
she's young that you do not
want to do when she is old.
And the exact same
thing applies here.
Do not answer email at
night and on the weekends
if you don't want
to start doing that
for the rest of your career.
Because the minute you
stop, you're slacking.
Well, not working on a Saturday
is not slacking, but if you've
done it for six years,
and you have a kid,
and all of a sudden someone
can't rely on you-- like, well,
what happened to so-and-so?
So level-set people.
It doesn't mean you
can't monitor emails.
It doesn't mean that you
can't keep an eye on things.
But don't create expectations
that for you to keep them up,
you will literally
make yourself crazy.
Because then you
really interfere
with your own well-being,
and other things
that matter to you that are
outside of this university.
I would also-- and this is for
those of you that are coming
close to the tenure process--
get your hands on a successful
dossier from your department
if you can.
So the dossier process is--
no offense, Judy-- is painful.
It is hard.
It's just a lot
that you have to do,
which I think, on the other
side, is quite helpful.
But the process of doing
it is quite challenging.
So don't reinvent the wheel
more than you have to.
You obviously have to
write up your own story.
But get an example
of someone who's
relatively recent
who's gone through that
can serve as a guide.
And then to the extent to which
you're willing to get advice--
because this is obviously
a very sensitive area--
get a couple of people to
read it and sort of say,
am I highlighting
the right points.
And hopefully,
getting to that point,
you've had pretty
clear conversations
with either your department
chair or your mentors about,
am I hitting the right
benchmarks, where do I
need to course correct,
and am I elevating
the right things in my dossier.
And those are conversations
which shouldn't happen
at year six or year seven.
They should be
happening annually.
You should really
know where you're at
relative to where you should be.
And importantly, you
should know where
you're at relative to yourself.
Don't be thinking about everyone
else in your department.
It is your track.
It is your time.
And it's really easy
to get caught up
in the noise around you.
And that brings me
to the general tips.
I think one of the things that
becomes important to success
in this environment, anywhere,
is your signal-to-noise ratio.
We are increasingly inundated
with invitations and asks,
or things that we should
be doing with our time.
And you have to get
good at both saying no--
kids are really good excuse
for that, or mentors,
you can use your
mentor as an excuse--
both saying no, but then
trying to figure out,
what should I be
focusing on right now.
Because I walk into
work and I think
that I know what my schedule
is going to look like.
And then x, y, and z happens,
and I have to reprioritize.
And so your ability to find
that needle in a haystack
and figure out what the
important nugget is right
now becomes really important.
And that's where, to Emily's
point, mentoring becomes key.
So there are a
few people, still,
where an opportunity
will come along,
and I'm not quite sure
if it makes sense,
and I'll just feed
it to them and say,
should I or shouldn't I. And
then I'll get a quick response.
But if you have a few
people in your life, mentors
that are both
formal and informal,
they can play that role.
And I would really urge you
to lean on them for that.
And ideally, you should sit
down with yourself and be honest
and say, OK, I'm smart,
I'm on faculty at Harvard,
but there's a lot of things
that don't do so well.
Figure out what your
holes are and plug them
with people who are really
good at plugging them.
So in my case, I am in a soft
money environment, where I have
to write grants all the time.
And so when I went on
faculty at Harvard,
I had made one of these lists.
And I felt very comfortable
in my topic area,
but I had no idea
how to write a grant.
So I attached myself to
the senior faculty member,
who worked in mental health,
we had zero topical overlap,
but he showed me how
to write a grant.
And that experience
was invaluable.
And so each of you
is going to have
the Achilles heel, the thing
that you're not so good at.
Just find the one or two people
that can really support you,
and make sure that
you're successful.
And then the other thing,
in terms of general advice,
would be--
and this goes back to staff--
collaborations are so important.
They're particularly
important for those of us
that are either in the School
of Public Health or the Medical
School.
But you're going to find
people that you work well with,
and then hold on really tight.
Because those
productive relationships
will pay dividends for
you professionally,
but then it's just
nice to go to work
and surround
yourself with people
that you enjoy working with.
And I think it's hard to
overemphasize that point.
So in terms of other
key skills to mention,
we haven't talked much
about email today.
And I'm one of these
people who, I do not
like to leave the office until
I can see all of my email
on one page.
It doesn't always happen.
But email drives me a
little bit crazy sometimes.
And I think that each
of us is going to have
our own system for managing it.
But it is worth spending a few
minutes and thinking about it.
And I wouldn't just do
that in the abstract.
There are people that you know
that probably work like you
and think like
you-- ask them, how
do you manage all
your email, what are
the strategies that you use.
And just figure out what is a
system that works well for you.
Because it will suck up all
of your time if you let it.
And so that's
something that I think
it is worth putting a
little bit of thought into.
And then the last thing--
and I had a really good
experience with this--
is don't make any decisions when
you're angry or you're tired.
And any time you get a new
opportunity, even if it sounds
perfect, give it 24 hours.
And find out, do I want
to work with that person,
does that person have
a reputation which
may hurt me later.
Because it is so much better
to say no gracefully than to
have to extract yourself
because of a bad experience.
Because anywhere--
particularly, I
think, at Harvard-- your
reputation is your currency.
And if it gets
damaged because you
get into a bad
working relationship
that you perhaps could
have prevented with better
knowledge, those can
be pretty hard things
to course-correct from.
So I'd be thoughtful,
I'd be careful,
and I'd rely on a few
trusted colleagues
to help you navigate
the process.
And lastly, have fun.
I mean, I know that when I'm
here, I'm not with my kids.
And so there's obviously
trade-offs there.
I love my job, and
I love being a mom.
And I think that if you
allow this environment, which
is quite intense, to become
very, very stressful,
it's hard then to enjoy the
pleasurable things that we
should be doing
when we're not here.
And so figuring out
what works for you,
and listening to your
own sort of non-verbals,
and how you respond
to situations
becomes really important.
And I want to extend
my congratulations
in welcoming you all here.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON MITCHELL: So thanks,
Judy, for organizing this.
I think I was at the
very first one of these
some number of years ago.
I've, in general, found myself
in a very reminiscent mood,
and I think in large
part because I just
passed the 20 year mark
of being here at Harvard.
I know that's when I
came because I drove up
on the morning after Princess
Diana had died on August 31,
1997.
And so it's really stuck in my
memory when exactly that was.
And I think partly from having
just passed that anniversary,
and also I'm thinking
about this, this event,
I've spent a lot of the
last couple of weeks
thinking about two things.
One, my perceptions
of how Harvard
has changed the most in the
years since I've been here,
and then also how I've changed
at Harvard in that 20 year
period.
And what I realized--
I think by surprise,
it wasn't something
I had in the back
of my head even--
is that both of those
have landed on teaching--
both Harvard's
approach to teaching,
and my own thoughts about
how teaching has changed me.
So I thought I would just
spend a few minutes talking
about reflections
on both of those.
And then I've actually gotten
some additional thoughts
from all the wonderful
comments that came before me.
So if I have time, I'll
augment, amplify some
of what you've heard before.
So you heard Judy say,
right from the beginning,
that Harvard has changed
quite a bit with regard
to how it thinks about its
junior faculty members,
it's non-tenured
faculty members.
And as you know-- you've
probably already sensed this
if you've been here in
any capacity before--
you know that Harvard is
kind of a strange place.
Like, it likes to do things
in its own particular way,
even though other
places have kind
of-- you would have thought--
worked out some of the kinks.
And one of the ways that
Harvard was strange until fairly
recently was that almost
all of the tenured faculty
came from outside of its ranks.
The non-tenured faculty were
here for some number of years
before typically moving on
to some other institution.
And that created a
lot of strangeness,
and strange dynamics
between faculty,
and faculty and
students, and lots
of senior people in
their 60s and 70s,
and then a bunch of younger
people in their 30s,
and no one in between.
But one of the ways that I
think it created strangeness
was really around teaching.
Because when you think about
what an institution might
do in bringing folks from
outside, it's typically,
you're looking for the best
scholars in that field--
the best historian of science,
or the best chemical engineer.
And you may pay less attention
to whether that person's
a wonderful teacher.
And so what kind of happened
was that senior faculty--
and I should also
say, many people
who were thinking
about coming to Harvard
might have found it
attractive to come to a place
where teaching was
emphasized less than
at their previous institution.
So much of the teaching devolved
to the younger, junior faculty.
But there was also a sense that
teachers are sort of born, not
made, and that there
just wasn't much one
could do to influence teaching.
You either had the
knack for it or not.
And so I think around the time
that the tenure system changed,
there was also this
realization that we
could be approaching teaching
the same way that we approach
many of our mentoring
activities--
to take individuals who
were new to the classroom,
or new to the kinds of teaching
they were being asked to do,
whether it be case methods or
teaching a big lecture course,
and to try to work
with those individuals
to improve what it is
they did in the classroom.
And so over the
last 10 or 15 years,
Harvard's made what I consider
to be a very sizable investment
in the infrastructure around
teaching and learning.
So I'll just mention a couple
of those things that are--
and as others have said before,
I have a particular lens,
being an FAS faculty member.
So not all of this is
relevant to individuals
in the other schools.
But I think what is true across
the schools is the renewed
emphasis on trying
to help individuals--
especially our new assistant,
associate professors--
figure out how to be most
effective in the classroom.
So under the umbrella of
"Harvard likes to do things
in its own way," what
Harvard has not done,
at least not in my department,
and I don't think across
the FAS-- although, it might
be different in your schools--
is some of the things that
other institutions have done.
For instance, in the FAS,
there's no FAS-wide policy
that your teaching is reviewed
by some other faculty member.
Nobody has literally ever come
into my classroom in the 10
years I've been teaching
here to try to give me tips.
That may happen in
your department.
I hope it does.
But there's no kind
of expectation.
I know other places, that's
actually built formally
into the mentoring process.
And unlike other
places, there's nobody
who's ever reviewed a
syllabus I've written.
I've just been asked--
I have, for the last 10 years,
been teaching Intro Psych.
I got a bunch of PowerPoint
slides from the other person
who teaches it.
And that's been the extent
to which anybody knows
what I do inside my classroom.
So unlike, let's say at Yale,
there's no committee in the FAS
that reviews course syllabi.
This is kind of crazy when you
think about it in this way.
So it's a little bit of
the quirkiness of Harvard.
But I think it's also in the
spirit of Harvard trying to
instead not micromanage what
goes on inside your classroom.
But instead, the FAS
and the university
have taken the approach of
trying to build infrastructure
to invest in systemic places
where faculty members can
improve their teaching and
access resources for improving
pedagogy.
So I'll mention a few of those.
And if you want to follow
up with me at any point,
I'd be happy to
talk more with you.
So two things that will
be relevant for, I think,
everyone in this room is the
Bok Center, which I'm sure most
of you have heard about by now.
And the Bok Center
was originally created
with kind of a limited
mindset to think about,
how do we improve the
day-to-day, nuts-and-bolts
aspects of teaching.
So when I first
encountered the Bok Center
as a graduate student
in the late '90s,
lots of what they
did was to say, let's
talk about what's
going to happen
on the very first day of class.
Let's workshop that.
And that was
incredibly valuable.
And as I got further
in my career,
I could access the Bok
Center for other kinds
of nuts-and-bolts issues--
I'm having trouble figuring
out how to lecture effectively
in time management.
And I had people help work
with me to think through,
why are your lecturers
not feeling right,
how can you manage
your time better.
And you can still
access the Bok Center
for those kinds of
nuts-and-bolts sorts
of concerns.
And I would encourage you
to go over there, even
in advance of actually
teaching your first class,
to just talk to them
about tips about what
to do on the first
day of class, how
do you manage your time in a
120 minute lecture, et cetera.
But recently, as you know,
the world has changed.
And the 120 minute
lecture is not
the only format we
have available to us,
nor is the 5 to 10 page paper.
And so partly spurred on
by innovations and advances
with digital learning,
the Bok Center,
and also other parts
of the university which
I'll talk about
in just a second,
have also been very
interested in helping
faculty think through what
they could be doing differently
in their class.
So to think through,
sure, I know
that the five page paper
has been effective for you
as a learner--
that the 120 minute
lecture worked for you,
but given your goals
in this course,
are there other ways that you
might approach the material--
everything from the
famed flipped classroom
that you've heard a lot about
to just thinking through what
kinds of assignments
you might challenge
your students with that are
different from the kinds
of assignments that
you encountered
when you were an undergraduate.
So part of that can be accessed
through the Bok Center.
And again, I encourage
you as you're
thinking about your courses to
talk to folks over there, who,
you could disregard all
of their suggestions,
but will at least help you
think in a different way
than you're probably
used to about what's
possible inside your classroom.
At the same time,
the university has
other university-wide programs.
So Peter Bol, who's the
Vice Provost for Advances
in Learning, runs
a couple of groups
that have a variety of
different initiatives.
One is, Peter's group
hosts an entire library
of digital resources.
So that could be
everything from,
hey, I'm teaching this
course, Intro Psych,
and I really need somebody
to talk to my students
about the hippocampus--
and I'm just not
an expert on the hippocampus.
So it turns out there's
some lecture that somebody
has filmed, somewhere.
And maybe it's just a
little five minute blurb,
and you can insert
that into your course--
either through
Canvas, the website,
or show it to your students.
So that's one kind
of digital resource.
But everything up to, I can't
get enough TFs for my course,
is there any other way I could
think about designing sections,
and all sorts of tools
around rethinking,
maybe I don't need to
have TFs for my course.
Maybe we can do this
peer-to-peer, among students.
Or maybe we can do some kind
of digital platforming of what
goes on inside sections.
So that's another area
where resources exist.
They're not widely
advertised, but I
know that group is very
eager to have faculty
from across the schools
access those resources.
And then finally, I'll mention
HILT, the Hauser Initiative
in Learning and Teaching,
which provides small, startup,
what they often call
Spark Grants, for faculty
who want to try something
new in their course.
That might be to create
some new resource,
or to help offset
personnel who will
help you think very differently
about what it is you're doing.
There's a couple of other
FAS-specific resources,
which I won't mention now.
But if you're
interested in accessing
some of these
pedagogical resources,
again, I'm happy to
talk about any of this.
Feel free to email
me at any point.
Part of my mission,
role, as faculty director
of the Program in
General Education,
is to talk to new faculty
about ideas they have.
Maybe not right now, as
you start your career here,
but things that you
might be interested
in sometime in the future.
So that's, I think, how
Harvard has changed--
at least, my
experience of Harvard
has changed-- since
I've come here.
And I thought I
would also just say
a little bit about how
teaching has changed me
as a scholar and intellectual.
So maybe some of you have
this intuition as well.
I felt like from the moment I
took Intro Psych as a freshman,
through everything I ever
did as a psychologist
for the next 10 years, was
sort of like this decreasingly
sized funnel.
It went from this
really big picture
of the field and
all the excitement
around learning the
whole panoply of what's
out there in psychology to
drilling down to very, very
specific problems
within the field,
writing grants and
papers, and becoming
an expert in something.
And I realized that the moment
where that really changed,
where the funnel
started expanding again,
was the moment that I
started teaching Intro Psych.
And what that course
has done for me,
it has really forced me to
start to think about the field
through a lens that's
much broader than the one
I get by just talking
to my graduate students,
or doing the kinds of
scholarly work that I do.
And so without
that experience, I
feel like I would be a much more
narrow intellectual, scholar,
academic than I ever would have
been after that experience.
And so I think, OK,
that's all well and good.
We like to be intellectuals.
But then I thought, just
for selfish reasons,
I feel like beyond just
my own personal enjoyment
of that experience, it
has actually affected
my scholarship in ways that I
could never have anticipated,
were I not to have the
teaching experience.
It's helped me
understand how what I do
fits into a much bigger picture.
It's often pointed
places out to me
where there just isn't research
being done, or not as much
as you'd like, and so
suggested questions
that I didn't actually
know were there.
And also, as someone
said, this place
is full of all sorts of
different kinds of people
from all sorts of
different walks of life.
And probably the most diverse
group on the entire campus
is our undergraduates.
And as you'll see as you're--
for those of you who are--
especially teaching
in the FAS, it's
an enormous source both
of personal joy, but also
intellectual
excitement to engage
in this way with students.
So that's just my own
personal reflection
on what it means to teach here.
Could I take a
couple more minutes?
OK.
Occasionally, you'll
hear someone talk
about how they've
gotten teaching relief,
as if they put teaching
in the same category
as dental pain and
hemorrhoids or something.
It never feels like that to me.
I have always thought,
yes, sometimes I'm
exhausted by the
demands of teaching,
but in general, I have gotten
more out of it than I think,
probably, my students
have gotten out of me.
I wanted to say a
couple other things that
were just spurred on
by various comments,
mostly to amplify them.
And Judy mentioned President
Faust's One Harvard Initiative,
which is fantastic.
But despite the attempt
to bring us all on board,
I want to remind everyone
here that there is
no such thing as one Harvard.
That is, Harvard
is not one thing.
I'm reminded of how--
I grew up in New York City.
And most people think about
New York City in a particular--
like a little slice.
They think of Times Square
and seeing Broadway plays.
And maybe getting
on a bus and seeing
Grant's tomb and the Statue
of Liberty or something.
But that's some very, very
tiny slice of New York City.
There's 7 million
other experiences
of New York City besides
that, most of which
have nothing to do with that.
And Harvard lends itself to the
same sorts of misconceptions.
Even now, when I think
about what Harvard
is, I think of some guy with
a big gray beard who speaks
in iambic pentameter at faculty
meetings, and starts off
by saying, in my 47
years here at Harvard,
I have never been so
angry, at whatever
it is that they're angry about.
And that is definitely
part of Harvard.
There is a Harvard
that does that.
And there's the Harvard of
Nobel laureates, and New Yorker
contributors, and
National Academy members,
and all of those things
that make Harvard wonderful.
And then there's the
Harvard of the people
in this room, the
people who are coming
to this place for
the first time,
often from different places
with completely different ways
of doing things, with a
completely different lens
on what's possible.
And there's the Harvard of
our graduate students, who
are eager to engage
for the first time
in the same serious
way that we do,
with the kinds of work that
animates us and keeps us up
at night.
And there are the
undergraduates,
as I mentioned before, who are
spectacular and open vessels
for the kinds of things that
we want to teach them about.
There are the administrators,
who make this place run.
And each of those groups
is contributing to Harvard
in its own particular way.
And so one of the things that
I have only recently begun
to realize is that there are
many paths through this place.
If you may want to be
that person in 47 years
time who gets up and throws a
shoe at the faculty meeting,
and that's wonderful, but
you may want your Harvard
to be one of political
activism, as we've
begun to see many of our
faculty are interested in.
Or you may want your
Harvard to be an investment
in undergraduates.
That's your particular slice
of what it means to be a here.
So I would just encourage
you to remind yourself
that just like your bus
tour of New York City
did not give you a sense
of what New York really
is, your particular
experience through Harvard
will be shaded by the one
path you take through here.
But that path can be much
more windy and multifaceted
than I think it appears
to us from the outside.
Last thing I'm going to say--
I think all of my colleagues
before me suggested to you--
they gave you the
advice to seek advice.
And I think that's really good.
And I would actually
go one step further,
which is that you
don't really want
to seek advice so much as
you want to seek criticism.
And the distinction
that I make is
that very few of my
colleagues has ever
been willing to answer the
question, what could I--
if I go to them and
say, what kind of advice
would you give me, unless
you're an economist,
you tend not to want
to demoralize people.
[LAUGHTER]
Or at least think
twice about it.
So it's been very hard for me
to extract meaningful advice
from that.
And I think what
tends to come out
is the person's own experience
of how he or she navigated
through academia.
But as I said before, there
are many different paths.
And there are many different
paths to getting tenure here.
No two people's
dossier looks the same.
And so you should take
that with a grain of salt,
that this was this
person's successful path
through to tenure, or
through Harvard, et cetera.
What I do find more valuable
is to actually give people
license to criticize
you, and to actually
put yourself in the way of
criticism as much as you can.
So the trick that I
use is to really play
on people's own ego.
That's why I'm a psychologist.
And it's to ask people
the question, what
would you do differently,
what would you
have done if you were me.
And very few of my colleagues
are comfortable saying,
oh, no, you did
it just perfectly.
I couldn't improve
upon what you did.
But people need to feel
licensed to say, oh, yeah,
I would have said
this differently,
or, I wouldn't have done
that, or whatever it is.
So I try to do this even now.
After every meeting I have--
I will ask Judy at the
end of this, what could
I have done differently--
every talk that I give,
both within my department
and also if I have close
friends outside the department.
So I would just encourage
you to try to put yourself
in the way of criticism as much
as possible with this growth
mindset at the
back of your head.
It's almost certain that you
are not an expert, or not
perfect at various
aspects of this job.
And so I think about,
if you were launching
a satellite to a distant planet,
you've got a couple of choices.
One is to get the trajectory
just right at the onset, which
is really hard--
impossible-- or to build
in a system that
can course-correct
as it gets there.
I would encourage you to
think about your own career
in that way.
You're unlikely to
have the trajectory set
just right at the very outset.
So think about how you
might build in mechanisms
for course-correcting.
So I'm going to stop there.
And like everyone else, I'm
very happy to answer questions.
[APPLAUSE]
ELIZABETH ANCARANA:
That was so interesting.
Thank you to each of you
for such great advice
for your colleagues.